it's about time
i think it's a good idea it's going to
be a disaster i think that's kind of
crazy at this point at this point it's
like you know if you're not vaccinated
it's like what are you doing i feel you
know i feel bad this whole thing it
should not be this way i mean i don't
know why people have to lose their jobs
they don't want to get vaccinated if
they're not vaccinated whatever i think
everyone should get vaccinated
we're all at risk
from people who aren't vaccinated
doesn't cost anything doesn't hurt
and it seems to work
i'm not a fan of the mayor
but at this point in time i really don't
care who makes these sweeping mandates
make them do it i don't think that
private
you know that private employers should
be mandating for their employees
requirement to be vaccinated i think
giving them their choice
people have to have choice i can
appreciate protecting and safety of the
public i think it's really really
important but i think that he has his
own agenda right now to get this stuff
in beforehand and why what we're not in
a silo here we know that there's a new a
new mayor coming in so why why is he
doing it now
i mean what you know because he wants to
run for president what's the point
we're going to go into another bad phase
and unless we get everybody vaccinated
mandated uh
we're going to start all over again
putting a vaccine i mean it should not
be you know
men i mean mandated for for kids you
know i think it's pretty well known that
it's not a big threat to children of
that age so to force a vaccine on people
that young is a bit crazy they spread it
and even if they're not getting terribly
sick themselves they can spread it to
somebody who can get very sick
some people might object to their child
being
vaccinated but i think that
it's better for the country to have
everyone who's eligible to just have
that protection
and not be able to spread
spread the disease further
kids they lose things really fast so i
was like you're not i don't really think
that's a good idea because i'm sure a
lot of kids at the age of five six you
know so on it's going to lose their card
and it's going to make it really hard to
like
try to get them to carry that card
around with them
well it seems safe for everybody so kids
could get the vaccination they got to
get vaccinated to go to public schools
so this is another vaccination you have
it for
smallpox and all the other
[Music]
illnesses that kids could get except for
being vaccinated so get vaccinated